au tour de l'ain d'imposer le
confinement à sa population une mesure
qui est entrée en vigueur à minuit dans
le pays 519 cas confirmés de coronavirus
ces dix morts selon le dernier bilan
officiel mardi soir les précisions avec
emilie gouache confinement total pour ce
géant de plus d'un milliard d'habitants
le premier ministre l'a annoncé ce mardi
affirmant que sauver la vie de chaque
indien et sa priorité pour sauver l'inde
chaque indien et pour vous sauver vous
et votre famille à partir de minuit ce
soir il y aura une interdiction totale
de sortir de chez vous un isolement de
la population qui doit durer trois
semaines
mais dans la capitale new delhi où seuls
les services essentiels sont désormais
autorisées le confinement ne semble pas
suffisant pour certains plutôt inquiet
car comme vous le voyez les gens sont
toujours dehors
aujourd'hui mon médecin m'a dit qu'il ya
un cas dans un bidonville de 25000
personnes à bombay les gens sont en
contact proche des uns avec les autres
les gens se déplace d'un endroit à un
autre ces risques est très risqué je
suis très inquiet les gens devraient
faire attention et ne devrait pas sortir
de chez eux
je ne suis pas inquiet pour mon
entreprise car elle continuera d'exister
seulement si les gens existent encore et
sont en sécurité et font attention
l'inde n'en est pas à ses premières
mesures pour éviter la propagation du
coronavirus le pays s'était déjà coupé
du reste du monde depuis le début du
mois
colonne vertébrale du réseau de
transport public le réseau ferroviaire
est à l'arrêt afin d'éviter que le virus
ne se propage à la faveur de
déplacements de populations
les vols internationaux sont interdits
d'entrée dans le territoire depuis
dimanche
le même jour un couvre feu a même été
déclaré à titre de test
le confinement de l'inde porte désormais
à plus de 2,6 milliards le nombre de
personnes appelées par leur autorité à
rester chez elle pour lutter contre la
propagation du coronavirus